good afternoon
for those of you who have not met I'm
Nancy Brown today I'm pleased to welcome
you to our discussion with Secretary
John Kerry focused on foreign policy
politics in global health
we're indebted to the Yale Institute for
Global Health for hosting this event
which is co-sponsored by the School of
Medicine the School of Nursing Dean
Kurth and the School of Public Health
Dean Vermont
the Yale Institute for Global Health is
the focal point for global health at
Yale bringing together expertise
knowledge from across the campus with
partners around the world with a center
of gravity located close to our schools
it represents the university-wide
mission by actively collaborating across
disciplines and seizing opportunities
for innovation
the Yale Institute for Global Health
aims to speed the translation of new
scientific discoveries into better
health John Kerry served as the 68th US
Secretary of State from 2013 to 2017 as
our nation's top diplomat he guided the
department strategy on nuclear
non-proliferation compatible extremism
and climate change his tenure included
the negotiation of an agreement with
Iran and the Paris climate agreement
from 1985 to 2013 secretary Kerry served
as a US senator from Massachusetts and
from 2009 to 2013 he chaired the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee as a member
of the US Naval Reserve lieutenant Kerry
served in Vietnam and received a Silver
Star a Bronze Star with the combat V and
three purple hearts a graduate of Yale
College and Boston College Law School
secretary Kerry is now Yale's
Distinguished Fellow for global affairs
where he leads the carry initiative at
the Jackson Institute for global affairs
secretary Kerry has made many
contributions to health policy during
his tenure in the US Senate he sponsored
or co-sponsored many pieces of
legislation that have greatly influenced
American global health efforts his
leadership was instrumental in enacting
the legislation that created the
president's
urgency Plan for AIDS relief and
authorize the United States to
participate in the creation of the
Global Fund to fight AIDS tuberculosis
and malaria as Secretary of State mr.
Kerry stressed the importance of global
health efforts in American foreign
policy including playing a role in the
response to the Ebola crisis today's
event will be moderated by dr. Saad
O'Mara director of the Yale Institute
for Global Health professor of medicine
at the Yale School of Medicine and Susan
Dwight bliss professor of epidemiology
of microbio microbial diseases at the
Yale School of Public Health be sure you
have enough titles Saad is also an
adjunct professor at the Yale School of
Nursing welcome
[Applause]
so before we start I want to add to the
tanks by welcome you on behalf of not
just the Yale Institute for Global
Health but our goal sponsoring schools
the School of Medicine School of Public
Health and School of Nursing and we'll
get right to it the u.s. contributes
substantially to the global health
enterprise both in terms of technical
efforts and resources and sometimes the
question is asked why should US
taxpayers pay for global health in other
words why should a mother in Kentucky
contribute to vaccine programs in
Katmandu because it will make her and
her entire community safer it's an
element first of all thank you for and
and it's great to be be here dr. uma
Thank You Dean Brown thank you there she
is thank you so much for what you do and
for great education everybody's getting
here
people don't automatically think you
know when I first was when I was in the
Senate and back in the early 90s dr.
Bill Frist and I he was then the
majority leader became involved in the
initial efforts to deal with hiv/aids
and in fact I wrote with him the first
legislation on AIDS and we actually got
Jesse Helms could be a supportive of it
we passed it in the Senate 100 to
nothing which you can't do today
anything in fact you can't pass anything
today except bad judges
so we worked hard on this in a
bipartisan manner which also doesn't
happen today there's a lot that isn't
happening today it should be happening
and it's really distressing the honesty
but we became involved in AIDS in Africa
and everybody said why are you doing
this what's it all about it came out of
a study that Bill Frist and I chaired
with CSIS maybe you know think-tank and
it was about security it's also about
the projection of American values and
interests simultaneously which is what
diplomacy is all about so we started the
process which then when I was about to
run against George Bush in 2003 I was at
a dinner in Washington I was asked to
give the Democratic comments it was an
AIDS dinner and Colin Powell : Powell
did the Republican line and he announced
that George Bush was going to invest
thirty billion dollars in this
initiative which taught me that just
running for office can sometimes
actually make something happen it
spurred this effort on and out of it
came PEPFAR which we're all very proud
of and I think it's a great
accomplishment we are on the brink of
the first generation of children being
born it's free and that makes everybody
better off it also global health is not
just a projection of American interest
it's not just a soft power as we call it
an exercise in soft power it is also
vital to the safety and security of our
country as well as countries all around
the world trans boundary diseases do not
attack whatever party happens to be in
the White House and its followers or
otherwise it's obviously not
permanent Ori and we're seeing with the
coronavirus the impacts of that we I
remember sitting in the Situation Room
in the White House one day and we were
told we were briefed by various CDC and
others that a million people were gonna
die over the course of the next four
months from Ebola and we did not know
what we did not know but we knew that it
was essential for the United States of
America to step up and offer leadership
and we did President Obama had the
courage to order 4,000 troops to West
Africa we Britain and France divided up
the task we took it on with Sierra Leone
with Guinea and Liberia and with a
mortality rate I think of about 40%
we managed where there were some I think
of us about 40,000 people were infected
and I think they're about 10 or 11
thousand deaths a mere fraction and we
stopped Ebola in its tracks so that's
the simple reason folks why we have to
invest in it and and there's more
reasons stability of communities
peacefulness of communities all of these
things are built up by building health
care delivery infrastructure and frankly
costs people don't think about this but
non communicable diseases are actually
the highest life takers and cost items
so whether it's you know malignancies or
pulmonary disease or cardiovascular
disease or other things there's a vast
impact in not providing health care
structure regrettably this
administration has cut billions of
dollars from that budget and it's
extraordinarily short-sighted and even
dangerous no thanks for that
responsibility off of you what you
mentioned around the Ebola crisis and
your engagement with that any thoughts
or any lessons for the novel coronavirus
outbreak that the world is seemed to it
seems to be
struggling with well yeah there are I
mean one is don't panic two don't shut
everything down automatically because
that could make matters worse three
you've got to build containment capacity
as rapidly as possible and in too many
cases one of the lessons is do it before
not afterwards the the the message is it
pays it's critical to build the adequate
health care delivery capacity and
containment capacity and that means
identifying that he is treating the
disease preventing future it requires a
layered approach and and thoughtfulness
and we're not engaged in that and kind
of enterprise the diplomacy of that kind
of effort has been diminished
regrettably under this administration so
I think if you look at coronavirus the
epicenter of which is obviously Wuhan
and and province I think there are now
72 or 77 thousand some are in their
cases certified and identified and I
think they're been around 2,000 plus
deaths so that's that's not a reason to
panic
it is a reason to be careful and and
spread this I think we've had three
deaths in the United States and I
correct somewhere in that but it's it's
a problem and it's only going to grow I
think that's the other lessons
from this we're on the cusp of a new age
of health threats I suspect and a lot of
it has to do with climate crisis we're
going to see we are seeing diseases that
are more persistent you all understand
the realities of that better than I do
but there are increasing viruses and
germs with with resistance capacity and
because of the warming we don't see a
dying out as we did which means more
prolonged and perhaps even more
egregious impacts as a result of these
diseases so I think it's you know I'm
just being honest about I don't want it
so fear but it is a scary time because
largely because we're not responding
adequately we're not preparing we're not
educating people about it which thank
God you are here but we're not doing
that broadly and there's too much bad
information out there there's a lot of
fear-mongering you see it in the corona
virus and some of the misinformation
that's being spread around about wuhan
biological warfare and other you know
causes of this dangerous stuff we're
living in an age of that kind of
dangerous danger where bots are
spreading you read the newspapers today
about how bots are attacking the science
of climate change and exacerbating the
problems with our ability to be able to
mobilize and build consensus around
things that science is telling us we
have to do so we have a big battle ahead
of us folks we all do you all have a big
part in this battle because you are
folks who within the various strata of
society have credibility you have your
validators of things that people in
public life have lost the capacity to
validate and we're trapped in a place in
our politics where there
no referee for the truth anymore and if
you read the book like how democracy is
fail or why democracies die you will
read that one of the steps leading
towards greater authoritarianism and
lack of adequate capacity to build
consensus is the taking away of the
referees to determine the truth so we
are living in a in a genuinely perilous
moment where everybody's participation
in the effort to restore our democracy
to its fullest and get the corruption
out most of all get the big money out of
American politics and the
corporatization of our politics out so
that we are not being fed a lot of
claptrap by people who have a greater
economic interest than they do a public
interest in what happens and it's a
fight the fight of a lifetime my friends
I tell you that having spent a lifetime
in public service this is the biggest
fight that we've ever been involved in
and we need you all of you to be part of
it
no thank you for for those thoughts no I
think being realistic about things and
being prepared about things is is an act
of sober statesmanship that one expects
from one's leaders sometimes more so
from our former leaders than current
leaders but I'll leave it at that
coming back to so coming back to PEPFAR
you were instrumental in that
legislation that policy and I remember
so those of us who were working on I was
involved with prevention to martyr to
child transmission of HIV trials in
early 2000 and we could not the sense of
helplessness for the we were able to
evaluate things for protecting the baby
if the mothers we didn't have the option
of treating the mother at that time and
I remember the sense of helplessness and
the discussion and global public health
was that how do we if more efficiently
the pie of resources available and then
it took an act of bipartisan
statesmanship to say look the pie is not
limited we can increase the size of the
pie and we can come together and and it
sounds like a log on memory when sort of
the two sides came together for a global
health emergency the question now is
that the challenges that was the
somewhat for certain countries it was
certainly an existential challenge at
that time but the nature partially
because of our success through PEPFAR
the nature of challenges has evolved so
how do we build on PEPFAR or leverage
that mechanism to go to PEPFAR 2.0 as
the kids say I think I don't want to
sound simplistic about this but I'm
being truthful when I say to you there
is a direct correlation between
presidential leadership and leadership
of the United States of America writ
large and our ability to organize the
world in these endeavors you don't see
Russia or China rushing to the United
nate's Security Council to declare in a
medical emergency or to urge countries
to come together around human rights
around any number of different critical
elements of life on this planet and in
the Ebola is an example not the only
example we took the lead President Obama
and I organized a White House organized
a UN Security Council special meeting
and we organized a meeting of all the
presidents when they came to New York
and we literally had a donors bidding
conference with presidents of these
countries which we held right in the you
New York
in the United Nations building where
countries came in obviously we pre
worked it and everybody made their
pledges and we put it into the fight
against Ebola we also I personally made
telephone calls to my counterparts in
China and Japan and elsewhere to say we
we understand you have these special
suits that were designed for something
else but they will work for Ebola can
you get X thousand of them shipped
immediately we'll help you
and we organized it we got health
workers out of China we organized this
effort and the world needs organization
folks that was the purpose putting the
UN together now fortunately we have
people who hate the UN in office we have
a Senate that can't ratify any UN
anything because they make this newly
developed neocon theory about
sovereignty that somehow it is a it is a
giving up of American sovereignty to do
anything in a multilateral context it's
the most absurd thing I've ever heard
there's no way to deal with nuclear even
Ronald Reagan went to wreck you Vic and
sat down with Gorbachev and said we're
going to get rid of 50,000 warheads that
are pointed at each other and talk to
the evil empire today you're not allowed
to talk to the evil empire wherever that
may be but that's a ran right now I
guess that's pretty much where where it
is focused and so we're not we're just
not governing neither effectively and in
some cases nor at all we have a
dysfunctional United States Congress
they don't pass budgets no person like
the World Health Organization CDC which
has had pretty significant cuts can plan
a long term future when you don't have
any clue what a continuing resolution is
going to put in your budget how do you
plan the committees don't do their work
which is each year to go through the
appropriations process it's all done in
one grand bargain for this continuing
resolution which concentrates power in
the hands of a few people who are lucky
enough to be at the table or a few
people who can get some scraps
by pleading with a committee chairman or
with the majority leader or whatever to
get something in there so it's
dysfunctional
it's a tragedy I spent 28 years and what
was supposed to be the world's greatest
deliberative body and right now it
barely deliberates that the greatest
testimony to that was the unholy moment
when United States senators tragically
against all common sense paid greater
homage to their party to their President
and to their own personal power than
they did to the Constitution of the
United States of America and so against
all the evidence they stand up and say
yeah you proved your case but we don't
think it's you know a matter of
impeachment Susan Collins I'll be call
her out on it Susan Collins I think he's
learned his lesson they really learned
he learned his lesson that he has
impunity because of you people that's
the lesson he learned and the result is
look at what's going on with the Justice
Department of the United States today I
mean literally institutions that our
founding fathers imagined had the
resilience and they have until now to be
able to stand up and it's not happening
so it is critical for the United States
to come back to your point to help be
the what Madeleine Albright
appropriately called the indispensable
nation and we have to get back to being
that because coming at us folks in this
field of global health is just an array
of challenges when I mean let me can I
take a moment just
you could take a few I've been involved
in climate change issue for since 1988
when Jim Hansen first testified to us
and I went to Rio for the Earth Summit I
was in Kyoto for the negotiations I've
been to most of the Conference of the
parties I had the privilege of going to
China within six weeks of being
secretary and negotiating with President
Xi and bringing the Chinese for the
first time to the table to help us make
Paris work by agreeing together that we
would work to decide what our emissions
reductions would be and we got Paris but
even with the getting of Paris folks if
we did everything in the Paris agreement
earth is going to rise in its
temperature tooth by three point seven
degrees centigrade we're not doing
everything we said we'd do in Paris we
are heading to four to four and a half
degrees and any scientist will tell you
that is the difference between
civilization and life and catastrophe
that is where we are heading and what
confounds me and angers me is that we do
not have leadership that is summoning
the world to the table to treat this
like a war which is literally what we
have to do we have to get on a war
footing we have to decide how much
faster than 2045 2030 2035
can we electrify all our vehicles
how much faster could we decarbonize all
the power sources for that electricity
how much faster can we move to build out
the infrastructure across America that
creates a smart grid and uses AI and
quantum computing to do the smart things
that we're supposed to be able to do
with technology these are the things we
have to be doing and nobody even summons
the meeting the g20 today produces 85%
of all the emissions on the planet and
82 percent of the energy of those 20
countries comes still from coal-fired
power plants
major financial institutions in our
country have invested one point nine
trillion dollars in future Coal Fired
power China is building 25 percent of
all the coal fire power in the world 52
countries still bringing coal online
this is insanity folks not only insanity
but all of that coal is what enhances
the problem of pulmonary diseases the
cancers the other things that people are
living with and those are gonna cost
developing countries vast sums of money
so what what is most aggravating is we
can win this battle still totally there
to be one biggest market the world has
ever seen four to five billion users
today going up to nine billion users by
2050 unprecedented opportunity for
growth and development of solar wind of
geothermal of hydro of all these things
and we should be doing the biggest R&D
incentive program we have ever done to
build a consortium globally that is
searching for the holy grail of dealing
with climate which is prolonged battery
storage you get 15 20 days of battery
storage we've won the battle because
then we've dealt with the base load
challenges for big companies and and for
our economies on a global basis still
there's a massive deployment of all
these resources we have to engage in and
this all has to do with you people
because you know when malnutrition hits
in massive ways because you can't grow
crops in certain places anymore
last year in Pakistan in one or two
cities 125 degrees folks people were
dying of just pure heat prostration
that's it you can't live and work as a
human being and that's conditions and
think of all the places in the
undeveloped world less developed world
where they don't have any
air-conditioning and we don't want him
to have it particularly at least with
the current you know
hydrochlorofluorocarbons etc but this is
the challenge of our lifetimes and we've
got to organize ourselves in a way that
takes advantage
our technological skill our innovative
skill our entrepreneurial capacity we
can win the battle still but the
scientists have said two years ago we
have 12 years now it's 10 and I'm
telling you here today it's not really
10 because you've got to make decisions
and implement them and they've got to
take hold and give you results in order
to avoid the worst consequences as
Secretary of State I went to Antarctica
and I went to the Arctic it were the
scientists in the Arctic who said mr.
secretary if you really want to
understand climate change you got to go
to Antarctic so I went and I saw the
scientists showing me the the massive
instability in the ice sheet now that
comes from warmer water spilling over
the continental shelf and going
underneath the ice and creating
instability and we've seen a area the
size of the state of Rhode Island broke
off if a couple years ago the Larsen Ice
Sheet and there's more to come
huge rift you could see along the entire
West Antarctic Ice Sheet which if it
were to melt or Rolex not melt in the
next 10 years gonna be a hundred year to
two hundred year project but the way
we're going folks it was 70 degrees in
Antarctica last week seventy degrees are
you kidding me so we got to get serious
about this and and understand the
reality these choices and for the health
world when people are climate refugees
we already have them today they're going
to be you know many more 250,000 people
a year and now slated to die of climate
change over the course of these next
years you're going to see problems with
water water quality food disease disease
will spread pandemic more likely to take
place a warming where we just don't have
the die-off of in of the microbes and so
forth I mean this is a I don't mean I'm
not trying to scare I'm just trying to
motivate you to recognize how big these
choices are we can still win this that's
not I'm not being falsely optimistic
about it absolutely winnable if we make
choices now
problem is not our capacity to do it
it's our lack of willpower the lack of
seriousness of purpose on a global basis
and that is what leadership is supposed
to be about and we have negative
leadership on this because the only
person in the United States in the world
who has pulled out of climate agreement
is our president I was in Madrid at the
conference of the parties a few what
December it failed it failed to do the
simple thing of setting up the mechanism
by which we were going to have the
metrics so when we go to Glasgow next in
December of this year to actually do the
raising of effort by countries we had
metrics by which we were going to
measure what that effort should be
that's what Madrid was about three
countries made us fail Australia which
then had the massive fires Brazil which
has massive disaster going on in the
Amazon and the United States of America
after all of the efforts that we have
made so folks it's as serious as it gets
right now and my hope is that we can
have a course correction in November of
2020 so that's a that's a good point
because you know we are a democracy and
as a country our investments depend on
the legislative branch coming together
with the executive branch and sort of
formulating policies like PEPFAR and the
Global Fund investment and so on and so
forth and those of us who pay attention
to some of these dynamics we haven't
seen a lot of discussion even in the
middle of a corona virus outbreak
obviously that's not the sole reason to
invest in global health we haven't seen
a lot of discussion in terms of the
candidate agenda and and so this is you
know in a non-partisan way even current
administration's also recalibrate their
priorities in an election season so
irrespective of the party there hasn't
been a lot of discussion of global
health and investments in global health
how do we make sure that this is part of
the the conversation or the agenda
well I think doing things like this is
helpful but it's not I mean no one is
running for president is going to hear
this today unfortunately so we have to
be very much in the face of the
candidates and their camps and create a
movement folks and and again I'm not
being tried about it I'll be very
explicit with you I've started a group
called world war zero and the purpose of
the group is to try to make climate
change an actual voting issue this time
and it's based on an experience that I
and others shared maybe some of you here
see a few gray hairs we in 1970 when I
first came back from Vietnam before I
protested the war I became involved in
this thing called Earth Day it was the
first one
inspired by Rachel Carson in 1962 with
Silent Spring we had this new movement
growing in America that didn't like
pollution and people demonstrated on
that one day 20 million Americans
unprecedented number came out of their
homes and said to the public body
politic we don't want to live next to a
toxic waste dump we don't want to drink
water that makes our children sick or
gives us cancer we don't want to watch
the Cuyahoga River light on fire which
it famously did frequently so how do you
do that well we politicized it we took
that movement of 20 million people we
targeted the 12 worst votes in the
United States Congress we labeled them
the Dirty Dozen after a big movie back
then and guess what we defeated seven of
the twelve you know what happened
there's nothing like watching your
colleagues go home because they lose a
race to stiffen the spines of the
survivors and what happened is we passed
the Clean Air Act the Safe Drinking
Water Act marine mammal protection
coastal zone management endangered
species and we created the Environmental
Protection Agency of the United States
of America we didn't even have one
that's what came out of that why a
simple reason we made the environment a
voting issue and Richard Nixon was so
taken by the fact that it was a voting
issue he spent a thousand words of his
State of the Union message trying to
co-opt the environment movement saying
how much it was important that we do X Y
& Z we did some of it
he signed the EPA into law so here's
what happened in 2016 when we got Donald
Trump we had a record low turnout a
choice between progressive whatever and
a guy who doesn't fit the standard of
the presidency under any equation and we
wind up with you know what we have today
you know the turnout was of eligible
voters in America fifty five point six
percent I've been an observer for
elections as a senator or secretary in
Sudan in the Philippines in in Kenya in
the West in have been a pal in the West
Bank and the in the territories and
other places and I got to tell you I've
seen people wait all day and hot Sun the
machine guns and tanks around and pot
potential of bombs going off for the
privilege of getting their thumb that
purple link that says I voted and in
Sudan I went up to somebody I said I'm
sorry you have to wait five hours to
vote and he said you kidding I've waited
50 years I'll wait
we got to do that in America folks when
I ran for president no four the turnout
was sixty two point three percent when
Obama won four years later it was sixty
three point seven percent you get the
drift
you know what the youth vote was in 2016
the people with the greatest stake in
the environment and the ones who are out
there doing climate stright and so forth
today 18 to 25 19 percent in 2018 when
we won back the house it went up to 31
percent 31 percent obviously still means
69 percent didn't think it was worth
voting
we can't do that so world war zero is
now bipartisan effort we have Arnold
Schwarzenegger governor of California
who did a lot on climate we got John
Kasich of Ohio we've got christie todd
whitman who was at the epa in governor
of new jersey we've got madeleine
albright President Clinton President
Carter
we have General Stanley McChrystal of
our armed forces we have Admiral Lee gun
who was chief of policy and planning at
the Pentagon we have the Archbishop of
Canterbury Justin Welby we have former
Prime Minister's of Britain Gordon Brown
David Cameron we've got former
presidents I mean run the list and we
have you know Hollywood people of
Leonardo DiCaprio and so forth we have
young people who are leading the climate
strike Katie eater young woman has taken
two years off from going to Stanford in
order to be part of this elite it and
and we're building an effort to
communicate with at least 10 million
conversations to Americans between now
and November and try to guarantee we get
that voter turnout up to 40 50 60 %
whatever and if we do we are gonna win
back our future in this country I
believe that
you know just a quick remark thanks for
alluding to the importance of social
movements and and sometimes it's useful
to leverage popular symbols like the I
think was a very smart idea to label it
the Dirty Dozen and we still remember
like it's in a collective memory so I
was thinking what is the what is an
analog now so maybe we should start a
green movement and call it the Shrek
collaborative based on the color
so now we'll switch to some of the
audience questions we asked and we
requested folks as they were coming in
to provide some questions and I will
take the liberty of paraphrasing one of
the questions that had struck me so what
is the biggest you know if you step back
and in terms of how we started
approaching health healthcare be it
individual health care or public health
or nursing care we were the big
revolution of the second part of the
20th century was that we move beyond
alchemy and wisdom based medicine to
evidence-based medicine and
evidence-based medicine and public
health has an implicit compact with the
population that truth matters and that
facts matter and those of you who
observed the 2004 election to our
consternation saw how facts were not the
currency for at least part of the it was
the first fake news cycle first big fake
news cycle so picking a random matter up
metaphor how do we prevent and mitigate
Swift boating of biomedical and public
health evidence it's a random metaphor
very random how do we prevent it or yes
mimic mitigate like how do we react I
don't want to mitigate it I don't want
to mitigate it I want to stop it okay
I I think that mitigating it is not
enough folks but I mean the way you
mitigate it is by countering it we
didn't we didn't have the money to
counter it adequately because I was the
last candidate for president to operate
under campaign finance reform restraints
I accepted to be within the campaign
finance regimen which meant we had X
amount of dollars given to us by the
federal government you didn't have to
raise money and I did it because I'd
been a longtime advocate of campaign
finance reform when I ran for the Senate
for 18 years I never took a dime of
political action committee money because
I thought we had to set an example for
how you can actually get elected without
it and why it's important after we did
the reform of john mccain and russ
feingold myself and others we I accepted
to work differently but what I learned
is you can't run for president itíd
States on the amount of money they were
given I wrote a long memo to Barack
Obama when he ran when he decided to run
I said under no circumstances can you
run under the campaign finance because I
had to pull out of Virginia I only lost
it by 0.2 1/2 or something I had to pull
out a Colorado similarly very close for
three weeks I was being pummeled we
couldn't answer any of the ads so you
can't run for price you can't run a
50-state campaign you have to be outside
which means raising billion dollars to
run for president united states both
sides by the way will spend enormous
sums of money and it's a huge distortion
track needless to say so how do we do it
how do you avoid that you you have to
fight back till we can change the worst
Supreme Court decision in modern history
Citizens United which has distorted the
economics of campaigns in our country
you've got to get the big money out of
the political structure so you can
actually talk to people and fight back
and and and have enough capacity to be
able to answer with with what the
truth is folks a lot of people are
confused and people are purposefully
confused I recommend a book by Naomi
Oreskes who was a professor of history
of science at Harvard and she wrote a
terrific book couple years ago called
merchants of doubt' and this book will
trace for you the very same scientists
who've been part of helping the spread
doubt about pesticides against Rachel
Carson who spread doubt about flame
retardants on kids pajamas who spread
doubt about nicotine and smoking who
spread doubt about acid rain and Dow
have spread doubt about climate change
it's the same group and they are funded
by the Heartland Institute by the George
G Marshall Institute by the American
Enterprise Institute and by its one
other the Cato Institute and so forth
they and all of them created for the
purpose and you read the lawyers the
lawyers memos have now been accrued as
part of the cases that were brought
against r.j. Reynolds which changed the
whole debate about cigarettes but the
the lawyers wrote these memos saying you
know we don't have to win the battle on
the facts we don't have to win the
outcome all we have to do is sow doubt
just spread doubt and that's what you
have seen in these last year's about
climate change they don't have any
peer-reviewed studies there are more
than six or seven thousand peer-reviewed
studies saying human beings are doing
this and they've been saying it for 10
or 20 years not one peer-reviewed study
to the contrary but you have deniers
maybe a hundred and twenty hundred and
thirty deniers in the United States
Congress so how are we supposed to
function there you've got to be able to
respond with truth you've got to be able
to hold those deniers accountable
politically and that takes the work of
individuals and democracy but
unfortunately in our system it also
takes money now we have a few
billionaire stepping up you saw one of
them the other night and not the best
display of billionaire
but at least he's spending his money in
the right cause folks he's a true
believer on climate he's working as
push-off and he has for years
legitimately and he's committed to try
to make sure we have enough resources to
respond to the Koch brothers and respond
to these entities which are willing to
so the doubt and and our great president
lied to the American people when he
pulled out in Paris saying that it's too
great a burden for the United States we
can't be part of the Paris agreement
that's a lie there's no burden no burden
at all it's an opportunity and whatever
we decided to do I want everybody here
to know we decided to do with big oil in
Paris Chevron Exxon Mobil beep they were
all there supporting the Paris agreement
so we're the biggest corporations in
America the 14 500 corporations were
there coca-cola Pepsi Google Apple all
supporting the Paris agreement because
they knew it was the right thing to do
and it also was not a burden because it
had transitions that were voluntary we
wrote our own plan every country wrote
its own plan so we we desperately need
obviously to get truth back on the table
we need some leadership that's going to
put real choices from the American
people and again I want to leave you
with feeling positive about this thing
we we can win this battle this is an
enormous marketplace if we will generate
more Rd initiative to play to America's
great strengths as an innovative
creative entrepreneurial society we will
find solutions this work I know people
who are chasing what's called net
negative emissions technology in in
Iceland they're taking co2 out of the
atmosphere putting it into the basalt
mixing it with a fluid and it turns into
stone there are people looking at all
kinds of ways of dealing with
painting and storing carbon dioxide ways
of of eliminating its burning all
together I'm looking right now at a
truck structure I just visited the plant
in Phoenix
it's a hydrogen fuel truck it will be
zero emissions the challenge is going to
be being a and it's an it's as powerful
it can go five hundred seven hundred
miles on one feeling I mean it's
incredibly capable but it it's fairly
energy intensive to produce the hydrogen
which as you all know is merely a
process of separating from water and and
and so it's available endlessly but we
have to figure out how to make sure
we're doing that with renewables
ultimately and it takes some work to get
there but all of this is is really
doable the same worker who's building a
BMW in South Carolina today that's an
internal combustion engine can build a
BMW that has a battery you know
obviously there are challenges to
recycling there are challenges to the
lithium and cadmium and rare earth
minerals you need to make them but in
the long run with other fuels and things
that will come online biofuels hydrogen
and so forth I think there's a just a
great future waiting for us in the doing
of this America we don't even have a
grid I don't you know that we don't have
an energy grid in the United States we
can't take clean energy from New England
and send it to other states we can't
take I was just in Iowa with these you
know I happen to like windmills I think
there's sort of a symbol of the future
you know they're beautiful
a lot of people don't want them in their
backyard they get it but in reality you
look at those we can't take that energy
and send it where it needs to be at some
time of the day but with AI and quantum
computing and all of the capacities were
developed folks we could run an
incredible grid think of the jobs in the
building out of a grid in America we
have a big hole in the middle of our
country we have an East Coast grid we
have a West Coast grid we have a little
line that goes from Chicago across the
Goda's and then Texas of course has its
own grid but we should be thinking about
this connection we have vast places
where we could build out solar 100
square miles of solar and you can
provide all the electricity needs in the
United States today but we're not doing
it we're not thinking about it we don't
have a means of transporting it across
the country
so let's build that out let's build a
high-speed rail I rode on a train in
China that goes 300 miles an hour put
the water on my table the attendant did
and the water didn't move as much as
that is moving now in the whole trip
half an hour from Beijing to Quan Chau
and and to Tianjin sorry and and it just
doesn't make sense that we're not we
have the Acela
you get it I mean the Acela can go 155
miles an hour do you know how much of
the trip from Washington New York it
does that 18 miles of the trip because
you cannot go underneath the Baltimore
Tunnel fast because the vibrations might
cave the tunnel in you can't go fast
over those rickety old bridges of the
Chesapeake because you wind up in the
Chesapeake these are just minor details
I know but what has happened that the
country that went to the moon invented
the Internet
you know do I mean honestly folks this
is that's what's depressing if we were
to get working we're gonna solve these
these problems I'm absolutely convinced
of it the question is not whether we
will get to a low no net carbon economy
the question is whether we get there in
time and that's up to all of us so now I
know why you don't have a trade called
the Chesapeake Express it so I have to
wrap up in the interest of time yeah and
and and really I'm pretty thankful for
you for discussing specific policy
solutions and ending on us note of
optimism in global health we try to
strike a balance of being realistic
about problems but also having an
attitude that the glass is never ninety
percent empty it's always 10 percent for
you know underscore folks I should say
thank you to you and people in the
community and though your predecessors
too because one of the things that
absolutely makes me a an optimist is the
reality of this curve of history if you
look at the things we're doing first of
all we're living better lives than any
of our forebears ever did you got to
stop and think about that yeah there are
a lot of crushing things we don't like
with the traffic and this and that so
forth but but we live longer we eat
better we are treated more effectively
in terms of medicine we
our solvent we're curing diseases we
never thought we might be able to cure
whether it's smallpox or polio or TB and
so forth we are we're we're if you're a
woman in the world today and pregnant
you are 50% more likely to live through
childbirth and you're 50% more likely
your child would live and be fed you
we're you know believe it or not you
don't think so because of Boko Haram and
al Qaeda and Isis and these other curses
but the reality is far far far fewer
people are dying violently today in the
world then at any time in the last
century when it was minions 30 million
Russians in the war six million Jews
millions of people would Vietnam Korea
World War one and and and the violence
of that period of time that's not
happening now and and you you have food
capacity production and so whether you
run a list of these things there's
there's really reason to to have
optimism because I mean when I was in
college global severe poverty was at 50%
today 450 million Chinese have been
brought in from poverty 400 and some
Indians who run around the world that
today the severe poverty level of the
rate of the world is at below 10% for
the first time in human history so it's
a progress it's uneven it's it's not
doing a lot of things we know we need to
do but I look at those things I look at
the fact that we actually went from
50,000 warheads pointed at each other
down to 1,550 we could go further the
START treaty we want to but these are
choices that that we have to make so I
honestly believe when I look at what
technology is doing and capable of doing
if we all make the right choices I
really do believe we can solve these
things President Kennedy reminded all of
us that you know all the problems we see
on the planet are human created
obviously with the exception of an earth
or a tsunami or a volcano or something
but everything else we face is human
created hatred I've never met a child
three years old or two-and-a-half years
old or hate somebody for the passion
that we see in the world today it's
taught it's taught and so we need
leaders and teachers who teach or teach
otherwise and and if we do these things
it's really worth the fight
thank you on that note before I thank
everyone I just want to take the
opportunity to you know to recognize
that we have a house full and that
filled up within a day and a half and
it's a testament of us announcing the
event we had a long waiting list etc and
it's not only a testament to our speaker
or sort of you know you mr. secretary
but also the interest across Yale in
global health issues and global health
is not new to Yale but the Yale
Institute for Global Health was
established to bring together to
leverage the various low sigh of
excellence in this great university in
service of some of the most salient
problems that we face as humans that are
related to global health and so in order
to move this effort forward we will be
starting a global health speaker and
dinner series this was part of that it
was the initial event and hopefully
you'll stay engaged and and there will
be much much more activity in this area
I want to abuse the privilege for one
minute short go ahead I'm gonna be a
proud dad and I'm gonna abuse the
privilege but the person you ought to
have come and talk about that who was
doing incredible job as my daughter
Vanessa who is a graduate of Yale and
works as a clinical as a critical care
physician at Mass General but that's 50
percent of her life the other 50 percent
is she has started a thing called seed
Global Health a CED seed global health
and she's building healthcare capacity
in five African countries until the
Obama administration until the Trump
administration came in
she had gotten and so help me God I
didn't make a phone call I didn't lift
the message she got the Peace Corps to
be involved the Peace Corps was there
until Trump came in and pulled the Peace
Corps out because her last name is
Carrie but she really knows this cold
and I think is a is a great advocate for
the principles that you are that you're
espousing you know thank you and it is
if I if I can say I my my guess is the
values that she carries forward in goba
house were nurtured through the model of
modern liberal education that Yale
continues to revitalize every few
decades and and that focus is now
increasingly on servant leadership and
that you know at least from a biased
perspective she owes it all the Yale we
had another to do and he said it
so on that note I want to specifically
thank several people including the three
Dean's
who score sponsored with DL Institute
for Global Health Dean Brown Dean Kurth
and the environment who is on anise Ella
right now and and specifically as other
sort of team members sonal em from your
team Shannon Legault Lisa Egan Kelsey
Smith rose de Eugenio and Mike skin acne
and we wouldn't have been able to do
this without you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]